digamos que aquí tenemos un rectángulo
más o menos algo así en el cual vamos a
trazar sus dos diagonales entonces esta
de acá es una de las diagonales algo así
y esta de acá es la otra diagonal vale
entonces ahí tenemos las dos diagonales
del rectángulo y supongamos que también
conocemos la altura de este rectángulo y
que mide digamos h lo voy a marcar por
aquí entonces esta altura mide h y que
también conocemos el largo del
rectángulo y ese largo mide wv entonces
esta longitud de acá mide w vale w ok
entonces lo que quiero mostrar en este
vídeo es que estos cuatro triángulos que
quedan divididos aquí adentro del
rectángulo por las diagonales tienen la
misma área vale ahora se ve medianamente
razonable que este triángulo de aquí
abajo que voy a sombrear con naranja y
este de acá tiene la misma área que el
de arriba ahorita los hombre o el de
arriba entonces este de abajo tiene la
misma área
que este de acá y el argumento pues en
realidad no está tan difícil porque si
te das cuenta a ambos de ángulos
ambos triángulos tienen como base a w
aquí abajo es este lado acá arriba es
este lado y ambos triángulos tienen
tienen como altura la mitad de la altura
del rectángulo si nos vamos de aquí para
acá nos queda un medio de h un medio de
h y si nos vamos de aquí para acá
también nos queda un medio de h porque
el rectángulo es una figura bien
simétrica sale un medio b h bueno eso se
puede probar un poco más formalmente
viendo que estos dos triángulos son
congruentes pero bueno creo que ahorita
más o menos nos la creemos y de por si
ahorita lo vamos a probar vale y por
otro lado también es más o menos
evidente o pues más o menos creíble que
este triángulo de acá que este triángulo
de la izquierda tiene la misma área que
este triángulo de la derecha
que este triángulo de acá de la derecha
y es más o menos el mismo argumento pero
ya no lo voy a repetir lo que voy a
hacer ahorita es ver lo que no es tan
obvio que es que los triángulos verdes
tienen la misma área que los triángulos
naranjas saleh bueno para hacer esto lo
que vamos a hacer es calcular las áreas
de los diferentes triángulos vamos a
empezar con los naranjas pero primero
déjame poner por acá la fórmula de área
para un triángulo vale bueno tenemos que
el área de un triángulo es igual a un
medio un medio multiplicado por su base
multiplicado por su altura vale entonces
vamos a utilizar esta fórmula de aquí en
los triángulos naranjas entonces digamos
este triángulo naranja tiene área área
igual a un medio multiplicado por la
base la base del triángulo sería wv el
largo del rectángulo un medio por w x la
mitad de la altura la mitad de la altura
ustedes le voy a poner un medio
de h de h vale otra vez la idea es que
estos dos triángulos quedan congruentes
y por lo tanto tienen la misma altura la
misma altura de aquí y aquí para acá y
de acá para acá bueno vamos a hacer las
cuentas para ver qué nos queda esto de
aquí es igual a un medio por un medio es
igual a un cuarto entonces nos quedaría
un cuarto x w x h muy bien ese es el
área de cada uno de estos triángulos
naranjas ahora vamos con las áreas
verdes jaja con las áreas verdes hasta
parece reserva ecológica pero bueno los
triángulos que tienen área verde que
tienen área verde ahora su área es igual
a un medio un medio de la base y ahora
hay que ser cuidadosos la base de estos
triángulos es la altura del rectángulo
espero que eso no sea confuso pero
observa tenemos que está este lado de
aquí que mide h es uno de los lados del
triángulo y a ese lo vamos a pensar como
la base entonces el área sería igual a
un medio de h&h voy a tomar el color
para que sea más claro de h x y ahora
tenemos que encontrar la altura de este
triángulo y para calcular la altura
simplemente nos vamos de aquí para acá
saleh nos damos cuenta que miden lo
mismo que aquí para cada otra vez por el
argumento de triángulos congruentes y
entonces cada una de estas alturas es
igual a la mitad a la mitad de w
vale entonces este de aquí es un medio
de w un medio de w y por lo tanto a que
hay que multiplicar por un medio de w de
w
bueno entonces con eso tenemos que el
área es igual a haciendo las cuentas es
igual a un medio por un medio que es un
cuarto x pues voy a poner primero está w
x w x h x h va otra vez aquí fue un poco
confuso porque la base del triángulo era
la altura del rectángulo pero bueno creo
que se ve la idea y listo con esto
terminamos tenemos que el área de cada
uno de los triángulos no importa si es
naranja o si es verde es un cuarto por w
por h y si lo piensas eso tiene todo el
sentido del mundo porque como son cuatro
triángulos de la misma área cada uno
debe tener un cuarto del área del
rectángulo
y el área del rectángulo es w por h